well in the same week I spent four and a
half minutes talking about a picture of
Joaquin Phoenix from the Joker movie
without any Joker makeup we now have 30
seconds of video of a screen test in
which is zooming into Joaquin Phoenix
and you kind of see glimpses of Joker
makeup and at the end we get Bill Murray
smiling totally looks like Bill Murray
but really my biggest takeaway of this
30 second video that came out a year
before this movie's gonna come out is
just the tone I hope it's advertising
the town nothing about this screams
comic book movie looks like this trailer
should be can Film Festival's winner for
best script and winner of the 2019 Palme
but I like the song the songs old super
depressing I should laugh but I cracked
that should be this movie in a nutshell
this is the first time I really sat back
and I was like what year does this take
place this is totally the 80s I don't
know why I didn't know that before I
should have known that before I probably
heard that before
I just forgot it his attire probably
should have tipped me off but miserable
people in 2018 they wear 80s clothes too
but as it's zooming before you see him
in clown makeup in the background you
see little glimpses of him and clown
makeup which is actually very nuance to
could represent the life he lives on
stage as a clown and he's just
reflecting on how miserable it makes him
or could represent the Joker the dark
murderous ass clown he hides deep down
inside coming to the surface in the end
he smiles and clown makeup but he's not
happy now my knee-jerk reaction was like
does it particularly look like the Joker
I never really saw this as Joker makeup
I think it's just him in clown makeup
he's probably a comedian clown performer
who then snaps and becomes the Joker
no way no Ironman marked one from the
movie resembles early Iron Man in the
comic books I see the sentiment and
would be reaction is the same I can
Entertainment Weekly if it was like
here's Iron Man from the new movie and
that's the picture we got a lot of
people be like that's not hims which the
response would be well that's like mark
1 there are steps to take before he
becomes what you know I don't even know
if I'm right about that that totally
could be the Joker but I kind of see it
as what he wears before he actually
becomes a comic-book villain that we
know this being an origin story and all
I do notice that you see little glimpses
wiping by of him in makeup kind of
behind him as transparent they do a good
job at lining up the painted face with
his normal face but I noticed his
clothes are Joker clothes he has the
purple coat the orange vest it looks
very Killing Joke
he does look like he's on a stage though
so it could be just him performing but
if the tone of this video speaks to the
tone of the movie
I'm down whatever they're doing I feel
o'clock in Phoenix gonna do a good job
or is it this 30-second test footage /
teaser Joaquin Phoenix Joker thing have
you seen it what do you think about it
and do you think that's him in full
Joker makeup or do you still think it's
pre Joker I haven't been every corner of
the Internet today but in the corners I
kind of peeked into it seemed to be the
conversation worth having and I'm
curious well now you know my tagging
that's just unfair so whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]